[Musik]
bis bald cast ist broadbent munich bei
emma in diesem kurs haben wir viel zu
besprechen
unser hauptthema ist klar von männern
war der erste teil
wir werden dann den zweiten teil nächste
woche besprechen aber als hintergrund
wird dich was zu die touristen
rostock ots selbst und natürlich zu
platon sagen hoffentlich wird es nicht
zu viel zeit auf lassen
übrigens dieser plan die davor
irgendwann sowieso schon auf der website
bei mir also unter meinem lehrstuhl also
einfach nicht googeln oder pda der lmu
sie kommen auf meine lehrstelle website
unter lehrveranstaltungen finden sie
genau diesen text ok alles sowieso im
internet also zuerst wollte ich eine
weitere gruppe von vor so kritiker
nennen die werden normalerweise nicht
aus forster kritiker genannt einfach
weil sie keine philosophen sind laut der
meinung der meisten wissenschaftlern das
sind die sophisten
dieses wort so fest so faktisch das
kommt aus dem griechischen wort sofia
und wahrscheinlich weiß jemand wie heißt
jemand hier ist so viel druck da heißt
natürlich so viel
es gibt es hier keine sofia war weil in
der jetzigen generation also unter
jüngeren mädels gibt es sehr viele sofia
alles weil es war vielleicht nicht so
mode geworden sind interessant ja die
sind sie sind philosophen
sie wollen so viele erwerben sie sind es
noch nicht also so viel heißt
weisheit genau also die sophisten waren
die weise männer und davon würde man
denken die sind wie es philosophen aber
besser die philosophen würden jetzt
würden es mögen weise seien die leute
sind haben sich schon die weisheit und
in der tat waren sie eigneten würden sie
eigentlich so betrachtet in griechenland
in der antike wir haben eine ganz andere
idee was wir unter so fest verstehen
oder so für uns heißt so frisch so was
wie unfair argumentieren oder angeben
also ob man irgendwas weiß wenn man das
selber nicht weiß und so weiter und so
fort
der grund wofür wir die sophisten so
einschätzen ist natürlich plattform
wurde auch das sollten wir aber
vorwiegend partie
diese wissen kommen sehr oft in den
dialogen vor als gegner oder der gegner
oder einfach gesprächspartner von
sokratis der gesprächspartner hier ist
nicht gerade ins fest aber ist duden
design student oder schüler war von
borjas eine von den bedeutendsten zu
festen und am anfang wie sie gesehen
haben dass sie das gelesen haben erwähnt
sotheby's tobias oder zum ersten mal
und weil es sorge dies fragt ihn ich
werde zurück dazu kommen solche fragen
was die tugend ist und er sagt
was du nicht hier als gorges gekommen
ist man all diese rede werden gehabt
darüber gehalten hat wie kann es sein
dass du nicht weißt was die tugend ist
und dann sagst ist ein schlechtes
gedächtnis also wahrscheinlich wirst
musste korrigiert was die tugend ist
aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau was er
gesagt hat vielleicht kannst du mir
sagen was die tugend ist das ist sehr
typisch sokratische also es gibt vollgas
und pro tages ist wahrscheinlich der
andere wovon sie vielleicht gehört haben
die waren beide säbel und in der antike
und hatten viele schüler haben sie es so
sagen ausgestellt als lehrer für reiche
junge männer war also die idee war ein
erfolgreicher trainer zum beispiel ist
jemand der so von haus aus reich ist und
dann ins politische leben eintreten und
durch rhetorik und das ist sehr wichtig
rhetorik dann in der politik erfolgreich
wird das hängt mit dem mit den tönen der
demokratie zusammen in athen
ja also hier in antiken athen haben wir
eine situation wo man durch rede halten
und leute überzeugend politische macht
erwerben kann denken wir an zum beispiel
per quiz ist eine der schlüssel ist so
sang seiner macht war dass er bessere
reden halten konnte
als andere trainer und deswegen haben
sie alle praktisch das gemacht was er
gesagt hat diese fristen waren nicht
unbedingt selbst politiker die haben
junge männer ausgebildet gute reden zu
halten damit sie die andere
überzeugen konnten und damit kann sie
gleich tun und beim macht erwerben
und die haben dann deswegen sehr viel
geld verlangt diese aufgabe das ist so
seien die kern
das ist so seien die kernaufgabe der
sophisten ist für der toreck zu
überbringen
und das finden wir vor allem mit goyas
er hat zum beispiel als paradigmen hat
er so test reden oder exemplare reden
geschrieben wo er zum beispiel für helen
gesprochen hat also er hat helen hass
der medizin oder elias hatte helen
verteidigt von den vorwürfen die immer
gegen hier moralisch ihre schlechte
moral gemacht würden
nun hat gezeigt dass ist das wäre fast
also jemand jemanden würde zum beispiel
heutzutage eine rede halten wo er zeigt
wie man michael jackson verteidigt
also bekannte der vielleicht michael
jackson hat zu guten ruf ich weiß nicht
das ist irgendwie durchwachsen
sein hof er ist ein bekannter der
schlechten ruf hat
amy winehouse ist mehr tragische gestalt
zu sein
charlie sheen perfekt vielleicht zu
abstrus
aber wenn sie wissen wer schon charlie
sheen ist wenn nicht können sie diese
junge dame nach der veranstaltung fragen
also jemand der sagt mel gibson also die
sind doch nicht so schlecht und die idee
ist so sagen ich kann ich kann jeden
verteidigen
das ist ein zeichen davon dass die reden
die man hier die wovon hier die rede ist
sozusagen die waren nicht nur politische
reden sondern auch im prozess weil diese
in demokratischen athen wenn jemanden
angeklagt würde oder verhaftet würde
müssten sie sich verteidigen oder
jemanden anstellen sie zu verteidigen
durch rede halten und auch mal sah hörte
ich dann im spiel in der rhetorik von
alles sagt er es gibt verschiedene arten
von rettig und es gibt es wenig dass man
im prozess benutzt in der politik und
beim begraben ist wenn jemand logan will
das sind die arten von red back und
georgiens vor allem wird damit sehr
verbunden
eine interessante frage sei nun sehr
wichtig für meine für den männern ist ob
die sophisten auch behauptet haben dass
sie die tugend liefern können also dass
sie junge männer nehmen können und diese
jungen männer gut machen oder tugend
machen und hier ist unsere
unsere belege sind ein bisschen
gespalten es gibt hinweise in anderen
autoren dass goetjes explizit gesagt hat
dass er das nicht tut also er tut nur er
sagt nur was andere leute überzeugen
können
das kommt sogar in bei platon in der
intent or bias vor
also er sagt ich bringe leute direkt bei
und damit können sie machen was sie
wollen
das sagt jemand der junge männer
beibringt zu boxen oder zu kämpfen und
dann sagt ja wenn ich jemanden so
kämpfen beibringe und dann geht er aus
den vögeln jemanden da bin ich doch
nicht schuld
mein eigentlicher weise wenn ich
jemanden rhetorik beibringe nun er
benutzt diese neue fähigkeit andere
leute von irgendwas beispiel zu
überzeugen bin ich auch nicht schon also
eher in den gorges stellt der retter ist
sozusagen moralischen neutral vor
aber dann sagt sigrid aber könntest du
nicht einen jungen mann den die tugend
beibringen
und dann sagte er ja das könnte ich auch
nur in ähnlicher weise in den männern
haben wir sehr die den eindruck dass
gott jetzt so sang sich als experte für
die tugenden präsentiert hat ob das
historisch wichtiges oder nicht ist
nicht klar
ein argumente gegen werde vielleicht
dass der andere berühmteste so fest zu
tages ist dafür berühmt dass er
behauptet hat dass jeder dass die
wahrheit von jedem gemessen wird wie er
gesagt hat also der spruch ist der
mensch ist der maßstab aller dinge
diejenige dass sie sind dass sie sind
diejenigen die nicht sind dass sie nicht
sind und in einem anderen dialog namens
wie man das auf deutsch schreibt und
genug also der abend wird verteidigers
vorgestellt als der erfinder des
relativismus
er behauptet dass dass das was jeder
denkt ist für diese diesen menschen wahr
und wahrheit ist nur das was für jeden
war ist und wenn sie meine meinung nicht
teilen
wenn es das was sie denken für das für
sie war und das was ich denke ist für
mich war also ist realismus und dass wir
den tmt titos widerlegt von sokratis und
wenn man das da das dort denkt könnte
man vielleicht denken ja ok anscheinend
hat pro tages dann noch nicht angeboten
die trugen weiße bringen weil er eben
gesagt hat ja es liegt bei jedem zu
entscheiden was für ihn die tugend ist
andererseits scheint es dass er auch
dann behauptet hat ja ich kann ich kann
ist so machen dass die das sachen gut
für sie scheine so zu sein scheint also
sozusagen gesagt dass er sein leben auch
in ihrer marken
meiner meinung nach verbessern kann
durch seine lehre und es ist vielleicht
eine art und weise zu bringen
auf jeden fall im allgemeinen könnte man
sagen dass die dass einerseits die
sophisten sich als weiße männer
vorgestellt haben diese weise waren dass
sie geld dafür verlangen konnten dass
die junge männer ausbilden konnten und
andererseits dass sie oft leute
überzeugen wollten von ansichten die sie
noch mit hatten das war eigentlich genau
das was sie so gut machen konnten die
könnten leute überzeugen und
normalerweise hat man die folgt folgende
dann erzählung von der beziehung
zwischen ihnen zu westen und auf diesen
platon die so wissen wann juristisch hat
haben sich für jeck interessiert sollte
diese plattform waren philosophen haben
es sich für die erste wahrheit
interessiert problem mit dieser
erzählung ist dass die griechen also die
die athener haben anscheinend socket
hieß es einst zur fest eingeschätzt
diesen eindruck gewinnen wir mindestens
hausarrest offen ist und weil sie hat
mir hat jemand hier sein theaterstück
die wolken gelesen vielleicht und zivil
sie können wir uns dann sagen dass sage
dies in diesem theaterstück vorkommt
oder
er wird verarscht praktisch uns aus der
dt weise und wird nicht nur mit den
solisten sondern auch mit den vorzug
artikeln verglichen
also er hat er hat interesse an
naturphilosophie wie dies vor so
kritiker also er spricht von heiße luft
buchstäblich weil er immer über wollten
serien über wolken 90 äußert und er
scheint zu denken dass seine aufgabe ist
junge männer beizubringen andere leute
zu überzeugen
auch viel die rede davon dass man andere
leute von alles überzeugen kann genau
wie bei google und das ist natürlich
etwas alarmierend man diese diese
ähnlichkeit diesem beispiel als offenes
gesehen hat zwischen des orga teams und
den zu fasten ist genau das gegenteil
was wir von platon von dem einzug der
plattform liefert das ist natürlich von
platon gezielt gemacht oder würde von
den weg gemacht er will in den dialogen
sorge das so vorstellen dass er in die
von dieser diesen vorwürfen eigentlich
bedeutet in am anfang der berühmten
apologie apollo 18 ist noch ein dialog
laut hans
am anfang hat es ist fast durch die
ganze den ganzen dialog ist der der
spricht und das ist eigentlich seine
verteidigungsrede als herr zu tode
verurteilt wurde
und ganz am anfang sagte er praktisch es
gibt leute die diese vorwürfe gegen mich
machen und die stimmen alle nichts ich
erzähle euch wie es wirklich ist und die
vorwürfe scheinen ähnlich so die sachen
die wir in den folgen von hass offenes
lesen also es scheint dass platon fast
ausdrücklich auf das öffentliches
hindeutet und ihnen teilweise
beschuldigt dafür das zeugnis
hingerichtet würde wobei natürlich offen
ist nicht der einzige wald der mit
beteiligt war
also ich würde sagen dass die es gibt
wir haben einen stärkeren kontrast
zwischen platon und den zuflüssen als
zwischen socke diesem sieg und den zu
wissen also im einsatz es ist eine sehr
sehr er ist sehr schwierig einzuschätzen
meistens haben wir nur wir haben keine
schriften von ihm nicht weil die schiffe
nicht erhalten sind sondern weil er
nicht schrieb erstens dass zweitens sind
die autoren die über ihn geschrieben
haben sehr verschieden wir haben ein mit
drei hauptfeld nämlich alles offen ist
in den wolken seiner von der historiker
der selbst dialoge mit sortis als
hauptfigur geschrieben hat und dann
klauen klar tanken wir fast ausschließen
als gute historische quelle weil der
plattform ist und jenny war
ich kann kaum glauben dass er jemals
sich hingesetzt hat eingebracht hat ich
werde nur socke thüs so darstellen wie
er war
mein lärm ein guter alter lehrer nein er
spielt mit sorge tiefs von anfang an um
und versucht immer sorgte dieses gestalt
zu nehmen und irgendwelche
philosophische punkte daraus zu machen
und einen punkt ein punkt den er machen
will ist das soccer thies ein
unermüdlicher forscher in die wahrheit
vor während dieses zu festen nur nach
überzeugung ausgerichtet waren also die
wollen nur plausible argumente finden
sorgt dies wollte wirklich die wahrheit
und das ist die einstellung die wir
haben sondern als philosophen und hat
einen etwas anderen paar eindruck von
seiner von also in seiner fans
interessant also interessanter autor
aber viel viel weniger einfallsreich als
plattform
also ich würde fast sagen alles ist
natürlich sehr schwierig als quali
meines ein theaterstückes komödie und so
weiter also wenn man sich wirklich für
soccer teams interessiert ich würde fast
sagen dass man mit seiner von anfangen
soll das vielleicht das nächste was wir
haben zu dem historischen sieg hieß wie
er auch genannt wird und dann so aus
denen und platon und als offenes lesen
auf jeden fall dass der city ist den und
der der uns interessiert diesen
prüfungen ist eigentlich der nicht der
historische socke thüs über wenn wir
nichts direktes wissen sondern der sorgt
der in den dialogen auftaucht was wissen
wir über diesen zur partie ist also ein
paar sachen sind sicherlich war also
auch über den historischen soccer teams
hat sich etwas seltsam benommen
erstens indem er barfuß in der agora
also im markt auf dem marktplatz immer
zu sehen war und hatte immer ein kreis
von jungen möglichst hübschen männern um
sich in dem glas kommt eine andere so
fest kalaitzis vor sehr sehr
interessante figur und er ist sagt
sotheby's du bist immer in der ecke mit
diesen jungen männern
es gibt einen schlechten eindruck und
diese und das ist das war verdächtig
nicht nur sexuell das auch aber weil er
alle andere der trainer ein verdacht
hatten dass er diese dass er diese junge
männer irgendwie verliert also hier
scheint ja fast ein anti so fest zu sein
also nimmt die junge männer und bringt
ihnen irgendwas bei was ihre väter nicht
gerne haben würden
und deswegen war ein vorwurf gegen ihn
wofür hingerichtet würde dass er die
jugend ruhen jetzt hat also das war ein
problem das andere problem war dass er
neue gott erfunden hat und das ist ein
hinweis auf eine ein weiterer
wahrscheinlich eine tatsache über den
historischen sieg hieß weil es kommt
auch in seiner vorne vor er hat er hat
immer eine stimme gehört eine göttliche
stimme und wenn er gerade dabei war
irgendetwas zu machen was er nicht
machen soll hat diese stimme ist diese
stimme ihnen davon abgeraten das nicht
machen aber auf griechisch
und dieses jahr hat nie die positive
vorschläge gemacht was die es gibt schon
ein beispiel in dem fall dauern aber
eigentlich kommen positive vorschläge
sondern nur diese abwertung also stopp
und das ist nicht die einzige
das ist wahrscheinlich was sie gedacht
haben als sie gesagt haben dass er neue
gott helfen hat das ist ein so genannter
drei mann der mit ihm gesprochen hat
aber er hat auch diese andere berühmte
verbindung mit den göttlichen die
geschichte kennen sie wahrscheinlich mit
dem orakel von delphi jemand diese
geschichte erzählen und john deutch als
ich kann schöne geschichte ja bitte
ich habe
st
ja und versionen diese geschichte kommen
in apologie von faton vor und auch in
der folge eher von zeno von hat auch
eine politisch beschrieben haben es
eigentlich ein freund von socket ist er
hin dass nach volker thies hat hatte
eigentlich nie verlassen
das auf im krieg also er war es so dass
immer man aber eigentlich immer einen
hatten es mit athens gebunden und ist es
sogar davor dass er kaum weg von von der
stadtmitte geht es gibt einen dialog wo
er praktisch vor den der mauer hat erst
mit einem freund und sagt jetzt ich
gesagt hab ich war noch nie hier also
also jemand der marienplatz nie verlässt
und deswegen sei nie gesehen hat ein
bisschen übertrieben aber nicht viel
ja okay als er wird als weißes der mann
beschrieben von und nicht nur von
irgendeinem anderen sondern von dem
orakel bei delphi also ist bestimmen und
dann denkt er dass qualität wird haben
sie das gemerkt dass unter jungen leuten
das jetzt selbst wie ein epidemie
schon lange es ist länger der fall also
nicht in meiner erfahrung war ich erst
seit 2005 in deutschland bin ich kann
bestätigen dass ist seit 2005 wickel
schlimm ist
das sind meine meine kinder erziehe
können und die freundinnen von die man
kennen denn die können keine satz äußern
und herrn haben anfang seines schlimmen
regenwald hoffentlich wenn meine kinder
die verfilmung nicht anschauen sehen
dass ich mich über sie lustig machen
in der vorlesung das wissen sie
wahrscheinlich stand auf jeden fall
ich bin doch überhaupt nicht ich weiß
gar nichts wirklich weiß ich überhaupt
nichts
und das ist so genannte sagen wir da
immer das ist so krass ist unwissen sein
berühmtes zitat ich weiß nur dass ich
nichts
ist das richtig weiß dass sie nichts und
wenn man natürlich einerseits ja genau
wie wieder genau wie ein also genau das
gegenteil eines festen zu sein weil sie
sind diese leute die behaupten die sind
so schlau und dann kommt er daher und
wird dort informiert dass er wieder weiß
ist er ist und er sagte nein bin ich
überhaupt nichts mein gott ich weiß
überhaupt nichts ich bin völlig
unwissend und dieser spruch
ist dann sozusagen seine verteidigung
implantologie ich bin kein angeber ich
gebe immer zu sagen dauern dass ich
nichts weiß und es kommt immer wieder
vor in den dialogen zum beispiel den
männern hier der von männern am anfang
gefragt kann man die tugend an den
leuten beibringen dass offensichtlich
eine anspielung auf das was diese wissen
gemacht haben und sagte dies sagt wieso
soll ich das wissen ich weiß nicht
einmal was die ubs wie soll ich wissen
ob das ab dass lehrer ist willkommen zu
dieser frage
auf jeden fall einerseits ist es gut
verbreiten zu sagen weil er sollte es
als gegenstück zu den touristen
deutschland kann andererseits wie kann
man philosoph sein wenn man überhaupt
keine weisheit hat
hier kann man natürlich ethnologisch
philosophie sehr ernst nehmen
philosophie ist es die liebe für
weisheit oder eindrang weisheit zu
erwerben ist es nicht die wahl zu
besitzen also die philosophen sind nicht
die leute die sich schon auskennen die
sind nicht die weiße männer die die
vorzüge und die sophisten behauptet die
waren sondern sind die leute die gerne
weiß werden würden und das ist okay ist
also ist der held der verlust fiel im
wahrsten sinne des wortes und wird immer
so was von platon dargestellt wie wir
sehen werden
hier traten immer und immer mehr
unzufrieden mit dieser einstellung weil
er und noch mehr als ort ließ überzeugt
sind dass philosoph ihr praktisches
wissen anbieten soll
oder können soll und deswegen versucht
die sogenannte sokratische methode zu
entkommen und besser den methoden
zu entwickeln wodurch wir wissen
erlangen können
kannst du wirkst du der geschichte die
seine verteidigung in der politik ist ja
ich bin unglaublich lästig ist jetzt in
marx mit meinem jungen freundin und wenn
andere leute daherkommen stelle ich
ihnen immer fragen so genannte
sokratische methode und ich zeige ihnen
dass sie nichts wissen
und das ist sozusagen der punchline war
er war der weißeste weil er der einzige
war der bürste dass er nicht weiß dass
wissen sie wahrscheinlich alle also die
geschichten der apologie ist er geht
ruhm in athen befragt alle was sie
wissen entdeckt dass sie überhaupt
nichts wissen
und dann denkt jetzt verstehe ich bin
der weiseste weil diese andere leute
glauben zu wissen wissen aber nichts ich
bin mindestens jemand der weiß dass er
nichts weiß und ich bin der einzige der
das weiß war die andere geben alle an
als ob sie was wissen
es gibt viele probleme hier übrigens zum
beispiel wenn er sagt dass er nichts
weiß
könnte man ihn zum beispiel fragen aber
du scheinst jeden tag die jaguars zu
finden dass du weißt anscheinend jaguar
ist oder
oder man könnte sagen
du weißt was dieses griechisches wort
heißt oder so was
und es gibt hier zwei alternative ich
könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich die ganze
vorlesung darüber sprechen dass einst
ein sehr grundlegendes problem bei
platon aber nur um das kurz schildern
eine alternative ist es sagen dass er
schon sachen weiß aber nichts wichtiges
da diesen eindruck hat man in der polo
geologie erste ergibt zu dass die leute
die theaterstücke die die haben eine art
wissen also sie können gut schreiben zum
beispiel aber sie haben kein wichtiges
wissen und wichtiges wissen und
wichtiges wissen wichtigen wissen
versteht zu katzis wissen über die
tugend und waren wie man leben soll
und das bringt uns zu einer gewissen
ähnlichkeit was sorgt hier ist zudem zu
füssen hat und nichts zu den vorzug
hatte können nämlich seine betonung auf
die ethik viele letzte woche gesehen
haben haben diese vorzeitiger über natur
flosse die kosmologie mathe physik
gesprochen hatte miss muss bla bla bla
bla aber ethische themen kommen sehr
selten vor dem markt es ist eigentlich
der einzige
die einzige ausnahme und das ist was
klischee aber es sind auch war so katies
repräsentiert eine wende in der
alltäglichen philosophie von kosmologie
und wissenschaft zu jack deswegen das
übrigens interessant dass alles offen
ließ ihn als wissenschaftler vorstellt
in dem feiern wir das gesagt von
software selbst das also der von den
fiktiven securities dass er als junger
mann sich sehr für naturphilosophie
interessiert hat aber dann
herausgefunden hat dass all die
physikalische theorien hatten und dann
hat er seine meinungen verändert aber
die athen war der sorge diese denen wir
bei platon auch in seiner von entdecken
ist ein philosoph der sich fast
ausschließlich für ethik interessiert
also eine eine möglichkeit deswegen ist
das wenn er sagt ich weiß nicht was er
damit meint ich weiß jetzt wichtig ist
man unter wichtiges verstehe ich
ethische lehre also wie ich leben soll
die andere möglichkeit ist dass er schon
das würde das würde voraussetzen dass er
überhaupt keine lehre in diese richtung
anzubieten hat also es wirklich
unwissend steht mit leeren händen da
sozusagen
und das würde gut zu seiner sokratischen
methode passen er fragt andere andere
leute immer ab was sie zu sagen haben
weil er keine antwort hat und er will
dringend herausfinden wie erleben soll
und deswegen jeden jeder mensch den er
begegnet er nimmt ihn
man sagt was kannst du mir sagen über
wie ich leben soll ich das ist dringend
ich muss das unbedingt herausfinden weil
ich weiß nicht wie ich leben soll
das ist die andere möglichkeit ist das
ja doch ansichten und sogar eine lehre
über das glückliche leben hat aber es
zählt nicht als wissen und vielleicht
würde es auch für andere leute auch
gelten sie haben zwar wissen über wie
über griechische sprache aber wo die
oder ist oder was auch immer
aber das zählt nicht aus wissen weil
wissen sehr fortgeschritten ist
was sie haben es wahre glaube die haben
überzeugungen aber die haben kein wissen
weil wissen ist was philosophisches und
sehr fortgeschritten
dieses thema werden wir sehr ausführlich
diskutieren in den kommenden
veranstaltungen
jetzt sollten tage der englischen krone
auf sagt wyss interessiert aktivität ja
das problem damit ist das wahre
überzeugung oder war in meinem
impliziert auch faktizität also die die
mine
das ist hilfreich in dem man sagen hat
die erste alternative ist dass er keine
ware also er hat keine ansichten die er
für wahrnimmt zweite möglichkeit ist er
hat an sich die er für wahrnimmt aber er
weiß dass das nicht wissen
erst war er überzeugt ist und hat keine
gute begründung dafür zum beispiel das
ist genau die die unterscheidung die ich
machen konnte
also entweder keine keine überzeugungen
oder überzeugungen die nicht alles
wissen zellen und dass das aber das
besondere an wissen kann nicht nur
faktisch cité zu sein weil eine wahre
überzeugung ist auch praktisch
das musste was die begründung oder
sicherheit vielleicht wahrscheinlich so
was wie sicherheit oder so ist ein
plattform nicht das ist ok hat jemand
fragen zu sagen ist also dieser frage
die wiedererkennung ist das jetzt
eigentlich eher ein rezept das plateau
in dem bund liegt sozusagen der das dann
auch das war das wie wollte gerade was
zu klar trennen das dialogen sagen
wurden im allgemeinen kann man sagen
dass je länger er schreibt desto mehr
neigt er dazu seine eigenen werde in den
mund sagte thies zu tun also am anfang
in den sogenannten sokratischen dialogen
stellt er mag die leute würden sagen
herstellt ist vor der wahl also immer
fragen und unwissend und dann mit der
zeit stellte ihn da als vieles auf der
theorien hat und ich glaube die meisten
leute würden sagen wenn ich denke das
ist zu einfach für die flure der
theologe glaubt ihm fast alle würden
sagen dass wieder erinnerung dass das
was wir nächste woche beschlossen werden
und diese vorlesung
das ist eine platonische theorie und als
sprachrohr dafür und es wird immer
offensichtlicher sind wir in der politik
haben wir diese ganz ganz komplizierte
politische theorien
es gibt vorstellungen niemand der denkt
dass das von scott ist entstand
ich bin relativ radikal in dem ich sagen
würde dass sogar die ersten die die
erste dialogen sind auch texte wo soll
dieser sprache dient und nicht
historisch akkurat dargestellt wird
das bringt mich auf jeden fall zu die
genau diese unterscheidung also jetzt
kommen wir zu platon platon war schule
das sorgt
relativ jung gestorben ist und nach und
es war erst nachdem solches hingerichtet
wurde dass platon angefangen hat zu
schreiben also sage diese immer eine
figur aus der vergangenheit in den
dialogen und es ist regelmäßig
unterscheidet man zwischen drei phasen
der schreib karriere platons die
sogenannte free dialoge die sogenannte
mittlere dialoge und die späte dialoge
und die haben jeweils also sehr
verschiedene charakter in den frühen
oder oft nur sokratischen gelungen
genannt ist sache ist immer der
hauptfigur begegnet jemanden
normalerweise jemand der ihr aus
irgendwelchen grundmann heißt experts
nehmen könnte expert wahrscheinlich für
eine ethische lehre zum beispiel thema
des dialogs nach ist mut und die gegner
oder die gesprächspartner ist sind alle
generalen also diesen soldaten kennen
also diese leute würde man meinen wissen
was ihr die truppen ist in diesem fall
die tour und mut und sagte jetzt fragt
was ist mut und dann liefern sie
beantworte und dann werden die antworten
abgeschossen von zapatero in ihrem kern
macht sie fast lächerlich und zeigt dass
sie überhaupt keine ahnung haben wovon
sie reden
das sind die früher dialoge dann kommen
die mittlere dialoge und diesen die
berühmteste und belebteste theologe klar
träumt man kann fasern die mittlere
dialoge sind politik und alles was uns
an die politik erinnert
also am pc sehr literarisch viele sehr
gut ausgedachte lehre und theorien und
sorgt dies ist immer noch dabei als
hauptfigur und ist der sprachrohr dafür
in die späte dialoge oder spätere
dialoge haben wir manchmal nicht mehr
aussprache wurde hauptfigur die sind mit
unbedingt so literarisch geprägt sind
oft sogar sehr trocken also wirklich
also kurze fragen beantwortete und die
thematisch geht er immer mehr in eine
mittelfristige richtung und weg von der
hektik
allerdings ist sein letztes werk
anscheinend die majors also die die
gesetze sorgt dies nicht der hauptfigur
ist sondern jemand der gesetze für eine
fiktive stadt vorstellt das ist ähnlich
wie die polit er aber das lässt
niemanden weil dieses buch so langweilig
ist ist auch sehr lang
und auch ob es auch unvollkommen also
jetzt nicht fertiggeschrieben
anscheinend als er gestorben ist
diese aufteilung ist sehr sehr
problematisch in mehreren hinsichten
also fast alle plattform forscher wurden
zustimmen dass es diese drei phasen gibt
aber fast keine zwei forscher wurden
völlig übereinstimmen welche theologie
in welcher phase sind und oft sogar
die rede davon dass ist traditionelle
dialoge gibt es zum beispiel männern hat
aspekte der front und aspekte der polit
er zb wird haben wir lehre und theorie
aber im grunde genommen hat es so also
dramatisch fühlte sich wie eine frühe
dialoge oder am freitag auch ist ähnlich
und wann würde sowas wie die apologie
geschrieben
wer weiß es gibt manche theologen die
sehr kontrovers sind mag hier nichts
also mit fragen zum beispiel nach ist
würden würde man fast immer als führe
dialogen im polit er per definitionem
ist mittlere tier zurück
ein paar männer die so oder so was ist
spät aber das ist sehr problematisch ich
zeige dass alles nur weil sie
wahrscheinlich lesen werden wenn sie
über platin lesen dass es diese drei
phasen gibt aber wie sollen wissen dass
es sehr verschwommen ist
ich denke es besser wenn man an
plattform denkt sie sollen ein als
modell im kopf haben jemand wie goethe
oder shakespeare und nicht jemand wie
bertrand russell
oder oder sogar weg in stein er ist
nicht ein philosoph der theorien hat die
theorien verändert und dann sich selbst
kritisiert das macht er auch er ist
vielmehr ein welt jenny der literatur
der auch philosoph ist und die wirken
sehr würde hauptsächlich glaube ich habe
das letzte wort er würde in der antike
vor allem geschätzt war es ein krieg ist
so schön war also er schreibt wirklich
wunderschön wenn er will
er kann andere leute nachahmen also kann
wie ein papagei schreiben wie alles
offen ist zum beispiel heißt so wie es
kommt in einem dialog der in dem
symposium vor
und dann haben wir eine rede von roßdorf
ii ist die sehr lustig ist also er ist
wirklich ein sehr vielseitige autor und
ich finde es lächerlich wenn leute sagen
ja wir können sozusagen seine sein
werdegang als philosoph claude die
dialoge erfolgen als ob die hauptsache
für ihn emma ist die theorie der formen
oder sowas wirklich überzeugend
darzustellen
hatte jemand hier eine frage eine letzte
frage allgemeine frage ist so plattform
bevor wir den männern besprechen werde
vielleicht warum er überhaupt dialoge
geschrieben hat
wie wir schon gesehen haben haben die
vor so kritiker sie haben gedichte
geschrieben zum beispiel
oder wie herr doug leeds diese
rätselhafte äußerungen gemacht aber die
art und weise wie platz an schreibt ist
mehr wie ein jemand der theaterstücke
schreibt das ist es sozusagen die
tragödie also wenn denn für die antike
leute hätten sie die dialoge angeschaut
und gedacht dass das nächste was die
kanten in die rettung der ein
theaterstück und so nahe liegen dass
sich zu fragen ja warum hat er keinen
kontrakt hatte geschrieben wie ein
normaler philosoph aber der erste der
wirklich zwar tisch schreibt ist alles
dort muss ein schüler
ich würde sagen also dass wenn man diese
frage das ist natürlich eine sehr
grundlegende frage und das ist auch eine
frage die man sehr lange diskutieren
könnte
aber wenn man sich fragt warum platten
dialoge geschrieben hat muss man nicht
vergessen dass es völlig unklar war
in welcher formats werke über flüsse wie
überhaupt haben sollen
es ist nicht als ob er sich um erst
blicken kann auf 2.000 jahre
philosophische traktate hass modelle
er ist vielmehr jemand der flüsse ferien
will aber wirklich sein frei war
wir schreiben will und da er sehr wie
gesagt sehr literarisch ist und sehr
ambitiös ich würde eher sagen dass per
gegen andere seriöse autoren
konkurrieren will und die seriöseste
autoren sind die leute die tragödien
geschehen haben oder eben human health j
das sind seine begleiter partner also
einfach vom genre her habe erstens dass
zweitens das auffälligste wenn man an
diese frage dialoge tanks das
auffälligste ist dass wir nie platt ins
eigene meinung bekommen
wir haben vorher gesagt sollte es dient
als sprachrohr für seine zelte für die
platonische leere
aber das setzt voraus dass alles das was
sie sagt ist klar tanzlehrer und das
nicht unbedingt erfahren
viele würden wir sind natürlich wieder
sehr umstritten aber viele viele platten
forscher würden sagen zum beispiel dass
man als so kritisch dass platon
absichtlich fehler in sorge dieses
mundschutz
und wir sollen die fälle dann entdecken
dann ist er nicht der sprachrohr ist
vielmehr wie ein dramatisches figur
und wenn man wirklich überlegt also
warum würde man dialoge schreiben was
wirklich zentral in dialog ist natürlich
dass es ein dialog ist also wäre es
nicht nur sondern sorgte ist uns sonst
jemand und wichtig für platon scheint zu
sein dass er mehr als eine meinung im
spiel haben kann
also das ist wichtig dass er ist mehr
ein philosoph der verschiedene
einstellungen und ansichten von außen
betrachten will als ein philosoph der
uns einfach seine eigene lehre auf der
hand ich finde es hat auch damit zu tun
deshalb vielleicht auch mit soccer teams
zu tun hat ja mal andere leute gefragt
bei dem er fragen gestellt und da das
kann man schwer ein traktat machen
werden es also wenn er wirklich die
socke thüs koalition zu sagen fortführen
will eine art und weise wie er im abgas
machen kann ist sorgt dies als fiktive
figur nehmen und andere effektive
figuren nehmen die ist eine fragen
beantworten sollen
also das sind ein paar erklärungen die
relativ oberflächlich sind dafür warum
er dialogischen hat eine tiefere
erklärung meiner meinung nach und ich
glaube dass sehr viel dafür spricht ist
dass platon und das hat vielleicht ein
bisschen mit der zweiten erklärungen zu
tun dass er meinungen von außen
betrachten werden ich würde sagen dass
platon philosophie nichts aus
darstellen will er will philosophie als
eine aktivität darstellten
also was wir machen und das machen wir
miteinander also unter uns
philosophieren wie ihr dialekt er schwer
sagen würde also die die altersteilzeit
mit jemandem zu sprechen
dialektik heißt ursprünglich wörter
auszutauschen mit jemanden und für ihn
ist ist diese die elektrische
vorgehensweise das ist sehr zentral in
der philosophie das ist die philosophie
laut plattform würde ich sagen und wie
man könnte fast meinen wenn man am
platon denkt was sind seine typische
ansichten oder theorien man denkt an die
unsterblichkeit der seele
natürlich an die ideen lehre und so
weiter und so fort
ich denke das ist ein die die kern
theorie oder ansichtskarten ist nichts
die ideen oder haben was mit der seele
oder die gott über politische theorie
natürlich findet man das alles bei
platon aber dass das einzige was
wirklich durch seine ganze werke
überlegt ist diese idee dass philosophie
ist ein versucht die wahrheit zu
entdecken
und ich denke dass er deswegen ein
solches immer als hauptfigur hat weil
erheben die folge sagt habe diese liebe
für die wahrheit repräsentiert also das
wäre schließlich meine erklärung warum
er immer dialogisch schreibt wobei ich
zugeben muss dass es ihm immer weniger
wichtig da scheint es zb ein paar männer
dies ist der hauptfigur paar manager ist
natürlich und
er sagt ja ich will dich jemand ich will
meine meine lehre in form von fragen und
antworten entdecken
aber ich will jemanden jung abfragen
weil ich will keinen ärger haben also
ich will dass er einfach immer die
offensichtlichste antworten gibt und da
haben wir anscheinend ein verlust an
thematische auseinandersetzung mit
anderen menschen
ok jetzt würde ich eigentlich den
männern besprechen aber jetzt können wir
eine kurze pause machen will jemand die
man nicht wirklich eine pause aber eine
ich mache eine pause in dem ich frage ob
jemand allgemeine fragen zu flattern hat
was war das andere beispiel
ja meint ich glaube
ja die frage ist also viele also
typische auslegung für plattform ist die
andere leute sind da weil sie die
falsche meinung haben und er werde durch
sagte dies zeigen dass sie nicht wissen
was sie aber was ich sagen möchte ist
das erstens sieht platon dass das sorgte
selbst irgendwie beschränkt ist das ist
eine methode hat seine einschränkungen
und es ist nicht unbedingt der fall dass
das was soll ich sagen immer die
wahrheit erst in leipzig partnern also
ich würde zustimmen
wie offen
manche würden sagen ja ich höre was
sagen nein
erstens war also ich glaube dass das
beste es ist ein wirklich sokratische im
sinne von mit dem historischen sorgt
dies zu tun
ja ich würde sagen also dass es nur mit
zweifelsfrei würde ich sagen wenn dann
ist hat es wahrscheinlich mehr mit einer
methode zu tun und die eben diese diese
dieser tendenz immer fragen zu stellen
wo uns sich selbst als unwissend zu
erkennen dass sie so kritisch es gibt
eine ethische lehre oder eine merial mit
mary thesen die zusammenhängen die wir
jetzt bei männern sehen werden
und das hat damit zu tun
das dass die tugend wissen ist und dass
niemand dass leute die toten nicht
besitzen die tugend nicht haben weil sie
unwissend sind ja und das könnte
historische gratis sein habe da bin ich
nicht so überzeugt also ich glaube das
ist vielleicht eine idealisierung der
lehre sokratis von seite von der seite
platons hat sich jemand fragen
mit lampen kann dieses ist nämlich das
recht auf die niederlage
so vermuten dass die islamisten
denn zu der zeit besonders beliebt waren
der anlagestruktur haben gegenstände die
nicht demokratisch trainieren kann es
sein dass laden sich deshalb stark
überlegen wie 2011 danach 500 jahre
hunderte verschiedene maschinen und
sonst irgendwas haben könnte sein meinte
ich glaube die frage ist mehr meine frau
ist natürlich sehr kompliziert und im
grunde genommen müssen wir uns immer
fragen die leute die reich genug sind
genügend zeit haben bücher zu kopieren
soll und warum werden sie bestimmte
bücher aus und die mama ist jetzt
mehrere gesagt habe ich es kann sein
dass das plateau durch gekommen ist weil
er so schön geschrieben hat mehr als das
mehr als eine lehre ist und wie zum
beispiel mein er ist hingegen über sehr
sehr kritisch fast immer also es kann
eigentlich nicht sein dass die athener
behalten wollten weil er/sie
geschmeichelt hat im gegenteil
andererseits demokratie gegenüber sehr
kritisch
und natürlich also dass es zeit ist die
zeit von alexander der große und nach
alexander haben wir natürlich
entsprechend weil eigentlich keine
direkten demokratie wer also ist es
kompliziert seien sie was sie zu
beflügeln würde ist dass die blu-ray
seite zu wissen es eigentlich vor
plattform mein gott es um pro tages sind
zeitgenossen von den vorzug hat über
diese nicht von platon es gibt noch zu
festen in der zeit platin zb sokratis
nicht mit socket zu verwechseln ich sage
mal esoc retis ist sorgt ist aber von
rpo
ist besser auf englisch weil englisch
heiße eishockeys einer von den besten
wissen also das ist
etwas skeptisch
natürlich ist die ist das verschwinden
der touristik mit dem verschwinden der
demokratie verbunden
selbst da wäre ich vielleicht vorsichtig
weil es gibt es die sogenannte zweite
sieg im zweiten jahrhundert nach
christus in new website des römischen
imperiums also man man darf nicht denken
dass rhetorik immer nur mit demokratie
verbunden sein kann aber nach welche
fragen männern so männern ist wie so oft
ein hübscher junger mann und das wird
mehrmals erwähnt im dialog zum beispiel
sagt sorry ich bin selbst wenn ich nicht
wüsste wie du aussiehst würde ich wissen
von dem von dem was du sagst dass du
hübsch bist weil du immer verlangt dass
ich mache was du willst und das machen
nur junge männer die so sagen was im
gegenzug anzubieten haben
und tatsächlich ist der erste satz für
im dialog ein ein gebot oder eine frage
die man an sotschis stadt also das
interessant es fängt nicht da damit an
das sorgt die seine flagge stellt
sondern stellt damit an dass mancity
seine frage stellt nun die frage wie vor
erwähnt habe ist ob die tugend der ba
ist also kann man andere leute
beibringen die trugen zu besitzen und
von dem was wir über diese wissen
gesehen haben sehen wir sofort dass das
ein heikles thema ist in dieser zeit
also eigentlich war sehr gefragt ist so
in einen ganz praktisch gesehen
könnte man sagen er will wissen ob es
wirklich sinnvoll ist das reiche weiter
geld zu den touristen gibt für diese
ausbildung in die in der tugend was die
junge in einer von den so wissen kriegen
sollen
die frage ist macht das überhaupt sinn
und socke dies kann natürlich nicht
sagen ja zumindest wenn er kann auch
nicht sagen nein die tugend des nicht
leer war ja nur weiß dass er nichts weiß
und deswegen macht er das typische
sokratische wenn jemand ihn eine frage
stellt fragte eine frage zurück wir
haben das natürlich immer noch mit der
sogenannten sokratischen methode die sie
gerade überhaupt nichts hautnah erleben
war das eine vorlesung ist also das was
ich mache ist praktisch das gegenteil
von sokratische methode ich glaub mir
vor mich hin und sie müssen zu hören
dass auf dass ich ab und zu fragen ob
jemand fragen hat das wirklich nicht
sokratische methode ist jemand zu lernen
dadurch dass man fragen stellt aber
dieses nichts zu vergessen dass wenn wir
ein sokratische lehrer denken denken wir
wahrscheinlich einen hochschullehrer der
eigentlich schon weiß was die antwort
ist aber er will nicht einfach sagen er
will dass die spenden des selber
entdecken und deswegen stellt thema
fragen ja das ist hier nicht der fall
sorgte dies hat anscheinend keine ahnung
was die tugend ist und deswegen kann er
nichts sagen ob die tun werber ist oder
nicht das ist zu sagen der anfang des
dialogs und das sollen wir kurz näher
betrachten
ihr habt gerade gesagt
das per keine ahnung hat was die jugend
ist also wenn man ihn fragt was ist die
türken das sagt nichts anzubieten tut
mir leid und man man kann dann sehen
sofort warum er unter dieser
voraussetzung nicht sagen könnte ob die
tuba ist er hat nichts dass er kein
schimmer stufen
das ist als ob ich sie frage an wissen
wissen sie ob der ba ist sie wissen
nicht was das ist
sie müssen das nicht hin schreiben
[Musik]
unglaublich wenn er keine ahnung hat
könnte man gut verstehen warum er nichts
sagen nicht bereit wäre zu sagen ob es
mehr war es oder nicht
im allgemeinen können wir sagen es gibt
es gibt irgendetwas und wenn es so sagen
wirklich ein 1 1 ein geschlossenes
schachtel ist für uns also wir wissen
nicht was es ist
dann können wir nichts sagen eine
bestimmte eigenschaft p ob es stimmt
dass xp ist das ist seine situation
okay aber natürlich ist das alles sehr
sehr unklar
es kann nicht sein dass solche teams
wirklich keine ahnung hat was zu kritik
zu was zu tun ist und im laufe des
dialoges werden wir sehen das ja sogar
viele viele meinungen über die tugend
hat und viele unten sich sehr oft
anscheinend wahrhaft äußern kann
zu diesem thema zum beispiel kann er
bestätigen dass die das mut oder oder
so fressen das also mäßigkeit der
gerechtigkeit er kann bestätigen dass
diese beispiele von trugen cent er kann
sagen dass trugen gut ist er kann sagen
dass sogar das tugend vielleicht das
wichtigste dinge im leben ist also
endlich sagen dass er keine ahnung hat
im stoxx im sinne des wortes was wir
vielleicht sagen können ist dass er eine
ahnung hat aber nur eine ahnung oder
vielleicht nur meinung
sie werden schon gemerkt haben dass das
ist genau die unterscheidung die vorher
gemacht habe mit dieser feststellung
wenn er sagt ich weiß nichts was ich
nicht weiß will er sagen ich bin
wirklich völlig unwissend also ich gehe
durch die welt ohne sachen zu verstehen
oder ohne zu wissen was los ist und dann
wäre es naheliegend zu sagen das kann
nicht überall der fall sein dass er weiß
wo die agora ist er hat mehr als eine
ahnung wurde oder ist das werden wir es
in dem von einigen zu sagen es geht hier
nur um durch bestimmte themen oder her
ist sagt ja ja ich habe
wir haben sehr viele meinungen manchmal
sehr starke meinungen das ist nur dass
ich zugebe dass sie nichts wissen sind
dann werden wir bei dieser diese
möglichkeit die wir nächste woche sehen
werden ist diese unterscheidung sehr
wichtig für den männern paradox was
nächste woche eine große rolle spielen
wird
ok
auf jeden fall da sagte thies diese
diese frage nicht beantworten kann muss
man die frage beantworten und dann haben
wir die zähne wo er sagt warst du nicht
da ist gar die es hier war bla bla bla
bla
nein ich kann er kann mich daran
erinnern melden mussten goldes ist leer
dann schildern für softies und das ist
was er sagt ich habe es auch auf papier
wollen zwei leute männern und zucker tee
stellen
wer hier gut ich über den kragen wollen
sie männern oder socke thüs sein männern
ist sehr sehr gut ausschauen und sorgt
dieses
okay jetzt kann ich definitiven nicht
aussuchen wer sorgt ersten termin und
also immer musik übrigens ich hätte
sagen sollen das hätte vielleicht sagen
sollen wenn es richtig ist körperlich
beschrieben wird wieder immer als
unglaublich hässlich und als beschrieben
also diese augen die so aus die und dann
hat das heißt stupsnase das sehr
berühmter seine stützen also hat also
nur die erste die die obere hälfte und
laut damit sie also flex oder umdrehen
weil die leute die das schwierig lesen
können sind die die händen sind
ich weiß was da steht
das ist ganz dramatisch hätte zwei
griechische
mehr
sollte es bleibt zu sagen dass dieses
personal suchen ist dass er vermögen die
angelegenheit damals zu verbreiten und
mit sondern bereiten die kleine
nein irgendwie selbst auslösen
das ist nichts dergleichen bis sie die
zwei besten ist auch nicht schwer zu
beschreiben dass sie das haus wie hinten
verein zu hause gut standgehalten und
dem mangel geworden keine andere gruppe
findet sowohl als knaben und mädchen und
eine zeit und so gibt es doch jahr
hatten wir andere suchen wir nach jeder
hand und 20 in jedem bereich hat für
jedes geschäft wieder von und ebenso das
glaube ich und du sagst meisten
ein
werden vorgenommen
entschieden als lügen und oder belästigt
fühlen
sie sind beide angestellt und werden
auch so verehrt
ich liebe das klopfen übrigens jedes mal
kleine herum dass ich in deutschland bin
das macht man nicht in englisch klagen
hier haben wir das ist eigentlich die
erste philosophische begegnung nun
versucht die frage zu beantworten und
sorgen schießt das ab das ist das erste
das erste erlebnis von mehreren die
männer haben wird als graf jetzt
wahrscheinlich also kommt darauf an wie
man zählt aber eigene vier mal versuchen
die tugenden zu definieren und jedes mal
wird es abgeschossen
das widerlegt und hier was ist hier das
problem was ist das problem mit seiner
definition würde ich sagen ja
also es ist also bienen habe ich hier
nicht zur verfügung
also wenn jemand sagt wie schaut's ein
philosophie student aus
da ist eine dass ein dasein schaut
einfach rum die sind hier überall also
nicht die schule die sagen die haben in
den stundensätzen die sind die alles
wissen so ist ein sehr und ich denke wir
sollten wirklich ab warum ist das so
mozilla kommt komm ich vielleicht ist
die u-bahn auf jeden fall
wir sollten wirklich überlegen wieso ist
das eine falsche antwort wieso es ist
schlecht nur beispiele zu geben und
keine einheitliche definition zu geben
und ich finde dass es wirklich eine eine
wichtige frage die man leicht über
schade wenn wir zurück zu dem was ich
gesagt habe das ist eigentlich eine sehr
praktische frage seine frage ist ist die
tugend leer war und ich muss das wissen
weil wenn sie leer ist das soll ich
einen lehrer holen wenn ich besitze ja
und es würde auch sinn machen diesen
lehrers diesem jahr dass er geld zu
geben
wenn nicht dann ist also praktisch eine
praktische frage und die frage
was ist die tugend ist nicht
offensichtlich eine praktische frage es
ist nur praktisch wichtig wenn es
wirklich stimmt dass wieder das
schreiben wenn es wirklich stimmt dass
ich eine definition von links haben muss
ein eine gute definition eine gute
antwort auf diese sogenannte tea ist die
frage tsd ist ist es die werden hofft
dass die fragen genannt ist die
popularität wissen was das ist uns
herausfinden ob es diese eigenschaft hat
nur dann ist es zu sagen für wen und
relevanz nur wenn es praktisch nützlich
ist und seine antwort ist durchaus
praktisch nützlich wenn sie wissen
wollen was ein tun hatte man hasst dann
sag ich dir wenn sie wissen wollen was
eine tugendhafte frau ist dann gibt ja
die falsche antwort aber er sagt es und
so weiter und so fort
also er kann in jedem fall sagen was die
tugend ist hier auch zu bemerken ist
dass sogar diese nicht bestreitet dass
diese beschreibung